well we certainly know that we were hit
65 million years ago by very large rock
from space Hollywood knows this with the
two blockbusters Armageddon a deep
impact so it must be true it was really
interesting in 95 Spielberg sent his
minions to a conference we're a number
of us were attending about this
particular hit and indeed there is great
danger out there we were surrounded by
asteroids some become earth crossing
Jupiter has a way of perturbing comets
and sending them from stable orbits to
earth-crossing orbits we will get hit
again how big the hit will be is only a
matter of time until we get something
that the same size that killed off the
dinosaurs showed humanity lasts long
enough that is but that size hit looks
like only once in a hundred million
years or more
we haven't had a hit that size for the
last 500 million years so it does look
like it's a rare event to have something
that big a 10 kilometer asteroid hit us
well no is it just the whole sense of
when is it going to happen again and it
appears that most of the big mass
extinction has been caused by these
nasty volcanic events the last one
didn't cause a mass extinction it was in
the tertiary period this was in my own
home state washing the state the
Columbia River basalts out came all this
basalt this liquid lava and of all the
carbon dioxide came out too but not
enough to cause the earth to go into a
really nasty nasty mass extinction their
mass extinction is caused by the basalts
again or simply by heating the world now
when you heat the world you heat the
poles more than you do the equatorial
region when that happens you start
losing circulation the only reason you
have wind now is you have a hot spot in
a cold spot and then they're time to a
cloak equilibrate well an ocean currents
same thing you have a cold Arctic a cold
Antarctic and then you warm them up the
ocean circulation systems dampen down
there's much less heat difference so
when we heated the poles to the point
that there was no longer or only very
sluggish ocean circulation the oceans go
anoxic they lose their oxygen they only
keep oxygenated now because of this
vigorous mixing well even when you have
oxygen in the atmosphere in contact with
the surface once you slow down any
circulation that whole Basin can lose
this oxygen the black sea is the same
case it sits under a 21 percent oxygen
atmosphere and yet the black sea except
for the top several meters is an toxic
it's black because it's producing a lot
of sulfur producing bacteria and there's
very nasty gases that are produced we
now think the big mass extinctions were
caused by global anoxia the oceans
themselves so sluggish that the hydrogen
sulfide bacteria are produced in huge
areas of the ocean bottom bubbles up to
the surface and starts killing things
rotten egg killing it would be extremely
nasty hydrogen sulfide poisoning is a
horrible death 200 hydrogen sulfide
molecules in among a million air
molecules is enough to kill a human I'm
just breathing in two hundred those
little things amid all the million
you've got of oxygen
and boom you're down horribly down so
this is a really nasty poison man that
was certainly present in past oceans
during these short-term global warming
events that's why it's really spooky
what we're doing now